[BLANK_AUDIO]
Ajay, what's wrong?
>> Well, I'm really having
a hard time finding a new home.
You see,
I like to be in a very specific area.
And it would be awesome if I could
tell the site which blocks I want.
And which blocks I do not want.
But I'm left having to go
through them one by one.
>> Ooh, that sounds really frustrating,
why don't try using my listing site?
You see, in my site, you can draw the
exact area that you want to live within,
and only search for
listings within that area.
You can leave out the shady
parts of the neighborhood.
>> Really?
Wow, thanks,
I'll be sure to check it out.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
>> Let's dive back into
the JavaScript API and
learn how to put such a dope
feature into our site.
Remember that library's parameter we
added earlier into our call to load
the API?
We're going to load the geometry
library when we load the API by using
the library's parameter.
Yep, that.
So a lot like a physical library,
the maps JavaScript API libraries
are full of useful things.
But they're only useful
when you use them.
And they take up extra
space if you don't.
Like all of your cookbooks.
It would be a lot better not to have
them sitting around if you're just going
to get takeout.
With the maps API libraries,
you only load what you need.
So we already have the geometry library
loaded, which allowed us to use that
cool spherical calculation to get
the heading for our street view image.
The geometry library is all about making
it easier to do complicated calculations
in the mapping space.
Essentially it allows you to skip
the math and let Google do the work for
you when trying to translate our 3D
world into the 2D mapping space.
There's also the visualization library.
Which it allows you to use your
data set to create heat maps or
other representations
of data concentration.
Read through the next section to
learn more about those two libraries.